The culmination of the entire Marvel Cinematic
Universe thus far premiered Monday, April
23rd in Los Angeles.
Those lucky enough to attend the momentous
first global screening of Avengers: Infinity
War have taken to social media to spill their
spoiler-free thoughts on the biggest cinematic
event of the decade.
Entertainment Weekly's Anthony Breznican reacted
to Infinity War using only a string of cryptic
emojis, while Emmy-winning journalist Kelley
L. Carter simply tweeted, "I. Am. Shook."
But others had more tantalizing things to
say about the film.
Most reactions have been positive thus far,
noting both the humor and the heart of Infinity
War, but some have taken special care to point
out the bigger flaws, particularly how the
film can feel exhausting or frustrating at
times.
The Playlist's Rodrigo Perez calls the film
...
"Stress-inducing, full of dread, darker than
usual, yet, funny as hell, and super entertaining."
"Sure, it's a punch fest, yeah, but I thoroughly
enjoyed it, especially the dynamics of all
these disparate team-ups.
Let's see a Thor and Rocket Raccoon buddy
comedy spin-off."
CinemaBlend editor Eric Eisenberg felt much
the same, tweeting,
"Holy hell.
Avengers: Infinity War is the real deal.
Was left breathless sitting in the theater.
Real consequences, stunning moments, awesome
character interaction, and some BIG and often
devastating surprises."
"I will add that it's pacing is kind of a
different beast, just because there are so
many plates spinning.
Excited to see it again just knowing how the
story unfolds."
Mike Ryan of UPROXXX wrote on Twitter that
the film feels like the epic opening of a
two-part film:
"Avengers: Infinity War has like ten legit
'chill down the spine' great moments.
But it's for sure the first half of a two-part
movie and I left a little unsatisfied/frustrated,
maybe by design … at least that's how I
feel right now, three hours later."
The Verge's Tasha Robinson noted that Civil
War fans should be thrilled, but …
"Avengers: Infinity War is basically Captain
America: Civil War times 20, except with less
hero-on-hero fighting.
I think people who loved the airport fight
in Civil War like I did will go nuts for this
film, and people who were bored will be 20
times as bored here."
Bilge Ebiri of the Village Voice shared that
sentiment, writing,
"Infinity War is exhausting.
*Exhausting*.
It all just turned into noise for me after
a while."
However, Ebiri did state that the "amazing
ending almost made up for the rest of it,"
and that Thanos is a "good, sad villain",
so it appears even the not-so-great parts
of Infinity War can be balanced with the insanely
satisfying ones.
But rest assured: plenty of reactions have
been completely celebratory.
Take Joshua Yehl of IGN Comics, who wrote
that Avengers: Infinity War left him ...
"...laughing, screaming, or crying the entire
way through […] stunned as the credits rolled,
speechless and sobbing."
Or consider People editor Nigel M. Smith's
more subdued reaction:
"Avengers: Infinity War is my second fave
Marvel movie after Black Panther.
The superhero interplay is hilarious and surprising
at every turn.
The action is monumental.
And there are actual stakes this time around.
[Marvel Studios president] Kevin Feige is
not f---ing around with this one."
Or maybe Collider editor-in-chief Steven Weintraub's
words will resonate most:
"Jaw on ground.
You are not ready for Avengers: Infinity War.
All you have to know is AVOID ALL SPOILERS!
Seriously.
Go in knowing as little as possible.
The Russo Brothers did the impossible.
Wow."
Overall, it seems people are really enjoying
Avengers: Infinity War, even if it didn't
hit every mark they hoped it would, and that
the consensus is that the film is massive
and moving, sometimes silly and always surprising,
and unlike anything we've ever seen in the
MCU before.
Fans can formulate their own opinions when
Avengers: Infinity War arrives in theaters
Friday, April 27th.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!